we were talking earlier about the herd
mentality how do you think people have a
herd mentality in getting their
entertainment career launched and how
can you spot an individual who's sort of
that dark sheep that's gonna dart ahead
I don't know that I would be the person
who spot them but I do think that
there's a lot of people that do but the
masses do and I think we have to
redefine in this country what
individualism is individualism isn't
necessarily being counterculture until
sick and tired of this concept that to
be different you have to be this rebel
you have to hate companies you have to
you know dress a certain way you have to
have certain beliefs you have to be
liberal this this notion of what an
individual is they're just conforming to
a different clique that they feel like
they fit into you know so you've got
these these people who feel like they
have to be part of a group some group
otherwise they can't stand I've always
been more about stand up my own kind of
guy I've never been a big group person I
think being different is something that
comes from inside of you it's the way
you think it's the way you conduct your
life it's the code of ethics if you live
by that to me is being different you
know wearing a suit or you know putting
a metal rod through your nose and piss
them out of police car
that's not it's not unique it's just
being an
in my view so I think that those people
who truly bring something unique to the
table and something unique that the
masses want because that's the business
side of it at the end of the day
nobody's in this to volunteer I mean
there's a business side to it if you
wouldn't talk about rlm law
and it make money and that's why they
call it show business whether or not
radio television print doesn't matter
art paintings whatever you have to be
able to make money at because that's how
we survive I mean you can you can diet
you can nail yourself to that cross if
you want say well no it's all about my
heart so about my heart and live under
bridge and there you go good luck with
that but you it's not enough to be
talented it's not enough to be smart at
business not enough to be any one of
these things it's a combination of
things and you have to kind of find a
way to bring them all together and that
person who can do with both will succeed
is that what you would term the artist
entrepreneur yes I didn't know they had
a term for it sure
yeah the artist entrepreneur if you
don't understand the business we think
about this how many times have you heard
about celebrity is getting screwed over
financially because they weren't paying
attention you have to understand the
business and one of the reasons why I
chose advertising sales is because now I
understand the money aspect of it I
understand how the people in power
decide which talent they're going to go
with because they can attach a dollar
amount to it because they have an
audience that they're trying to hit
they're going to set you know what's the
demand and then they take that demand
and they translate it to advertising
dollars because that's how you pay for
everything so understanding both sides
of that and in my particular case also
there's the other technical side of it
from working behind the scenes so I
think it makes you a better talent it
makes you a better business person
sitting around on is saying you know I
want this because I'm the talent I think
those days are starting to fade because
you have to be smarter about how you
manage your yourself and you don't want
to rely on everyone else because when
you rely on everyone else you put
yourself at risk for all kinds of
problems I maybe it's just being a
little more of a control freak but in my
view I think you have to be that you
know our artist entrepreneur as you put
it
you